comment vont les loustics préféré c'est
un peu forcée comme introduction est un
art bon vous savez très bien dans la
liste des trucs qu'on fait une fois par
an sur cette chaîne youtube il ya les
vidéos omegle et oui ça fait longtemps
plus tard la première date de 2013 14 on
a souvent fêter les anniversaires de la
chaîne donc je crois que l'anniversaire
de la chaîne c'est le 3 mars entre comme
ça mais à la place l'année dernière
j'avais fait une vidéo mais gueule dans
laquelle on ne fait pas l'anniversaire
de la chaîne mais dans laquelle je vous
piéger à l'aide d'un fonds vert ici
présents vous l'avez vu je peux leur
descend je voulais pas finir l'année
sans faire une vidéo dans laquelle vous
êtes on va pas faire comme la dernière
fois où vous souvenez vous je mettais
une perruque et je jouais à un
adolescent dans sa chambre fabrice tigré
à 1000% que c'était moi aujourd'hui on
va faire autre chose on va faire ça on
va s'incruster messieurs dames dans des
photos je vais tenir la pause et on va
voir si je me fais taper et si je me
fais pas zapper on va voir combien de
temps les gens mettent à me trouver j'ai
fait un tweet annonçant que j'étais sur
ma gueule mais j'ai pas dit que j'allais
faire ce petit jeu à l'aco avec des
images là est restée figée on va voir
comment les gens réagissent et après
aussi j'ai accessoirement acheter un
mannequin ça devait être le concept près
de la vidéo puis entre temps j'ai trouvé
cette idée de me maquiller en des photos
et de tenir la pause et je trouvais ça
plus rigolo mais on fera peut-être un
petit coup de maintenir vers la fin de
la vidéo ça c'est une casquette ou quoi
ok je suis prêt à ça ça fait
alors tu me vois non et 20h hier j'étais
derrière le frelon vert jus dans la
photo tu vas tu m'as fait non je te
promets l idée pas mauvaise ac c'est
excellent pas sûr ça me fait plaisir
tant à un bon set up touadi dont ab
merci le petit micro de casques le pin
est au top
tu passes bonnes vacances des très
bonnes tu as l'air de les passer quand
même avec les stores fermés à jouer un
peu au jeu vidéo je trouve
non je faisais les mêmes j'ai fait avant
toi je faisais les mais bon je te fais
des bisous à bientôt mon pad face bonnes
vacances
tiens photo c'est bien je te vois je te
vois bien jouer j'ai deux pages un coin
coin qui sont ouvertes à tous sa chance
mais toi tu es un malade que tu vas
gagner au loto a continué comme ça
allait mal et néry mais si ça va tu
passe de bonnes vacances super les
bonnes réponses
bah là tout de suite maintenant were
gars je m'amuse avec des enfants ah
ouais c'est drôle à cette image
j attendais bonne celle là je me suis
dit elle c'est encore quelqu'un qui ait
mis une fausse caméra elle est menée
chst et ça faisait de la peine que tu
mex
[Musique]
non tu ma bulle
oui merde alors tu vois à lire dès la
pause c'est là où tu vois ce que c'est
mon métier en 2019
c'est notre cité dans des images comme
un gros coup à l'un des juges était
grave rassure c'est ça mais je me fous
de votre gueule c'est horrible je suis
horrible ça va tu fasses bonnes vacances
abel et alors tu es quand même en
vacances donc c'est quand même bien
certains gènes battre l'estonie bon bah
écoute force à toi donnent tous ces
mâles fight alone tu peux la voir
je compte sur toi les amis laissez moi
vous présenter le deuxième des corps ah
oui qu'il est pas mal sur la waci
squeeze dans le siège du bim deuxième
rangée epide ses portes et roland est
allé trop loin mec je sais je suis
désolé je peux pas voir mon film avec
toi je peux pas voir le film
waouh y'a vraiment quelqu'un sur ce
siège en plus tu as presque eu beau en
disant ton truc au hasard c'est
incroyable je me fasse gaffe en tulle
allô allô attends j'ai entendu ce midi
là ouais ouais
est ce que tu me vois mieux ici une
belle pour toi base et frère de blague
eye-fi faire de blagues oui
[Musique]
ça va ça va très bien il y en a une mais
des trucs automatique du coup je me suis
dit je suis pour faire un jeu vendu du
mouvement dans le fond a bien été une
bonne vision il ya des gens je mets ça
ils voient pas incroyable yo yo de fonds
chez swiss fcba personne ne voit jamais
c'est ça commence mais au fond au cinéma
c'est chiant des magnifiques ton cinéma
c'est mon cinéma privée c'est la cuisine
du striz avec avec tous les milliards
d'euros j'ai pu faire cette salle et eux
c'est par ici des comédiens ils seront
sûrement déjà des films toute la journée
il faux papiers à ce quizz in the street
voilà sur cd à bientôt mon vieux face
bonnes vacances juste là d'orage qui
avec merci beaucoup au coeur c'est toi
on m'a rapporté que tu avais un fond
vert
mesdames et pourquoi je quitte la salle
de cinéma à chaque fois c'est la même
chose à chaque fois je commence à
m'amuser et les jours ils tombent ils
tombent les uns les autres et comme ils
sont mignons et gentil et pire veilhan
et d'haïti dont j'ai emmené dans une
salle du cinéma si tu peux utiliser ma
attend bon il reste trois décors
celui-là est drôle parce que c'est comme
ça ça aurait truc de gamin ça veut flag
oh c'est faux pas au [ __ ] mais oui
j'ai avec mes gros on est au travail on
est en pleine réunion je te fais des
gros bisous et je te souhaite de bonnes
vacances mon vieux un merci thierry
frémaux a bientôt en soit revue ciao
c'est vraiment squeeze le chien est
battu xian maintenant waouh c'est
incroyable cette blague bec j'en suis
fier regarde elle est vraiment beaucoup
toi je te montre la prochaine tu vas
voir tu vas me dire si tu aimes ton des
jeux de seconde je te dis quand c'est
bon ok ok vas-y tu peux regarder tu veux
un petit verdot peut-être quatre où tout
à fait j'aimerais bien un verre d'eau si
vous voulez pas de problème merci
beaucoup c'est pas mais ça aurait pu
être mieux mais ça aux [ __ ] aaa a pas
marché du tout
merci pour le morceau ça occuper une
minute de mon vol de 14 heures merci
beaucoup et ben c'est génial at envol en
fait ouais je suis en sachant très bien
ok bah c'est nickel bas j'espère qu'il
va se crasher aoc au revoir twizy
comment ça va et japonais des mèches
blondes l'école ton t-shirt dur coup à
battre amiens c'est une édition dignité
je les attends de seconde ne bouge pas
je reviens donc je pense quelque chose
vite fait regarde j'ai le nouveau tee
shirts comme moi aussi ouais j'ai pris
en rouge moi je trouve il est grave au
nom je le vois moi fort à l'arrière mais
vous savez quoi
oui toi etc où tout va très bien ma foi
tout va très bien et est en vacances et
au québec
wilt au québec et on inverse près de
chez toi je te près de chez moi et comme
ça on fait les vacances au j'aimerais
tellement cela serait pas mal écouté ce
que je te montre le prochain décor la de
la vidéo là le fond en avant-première tu
me dis ce que tu en penses tu es prête
brackley de l'eau c'est par ces mots
c'est quand même sur à merci tient aux
proviseurs impatience et voilà
maintenant vous avez vu le dernier des
corps dont je suis assez fier et
pourquoi je parle comme un commentateur
ça va encore sérieusement
bah ouais on prenne en photo toute la
journée c'est la paris games week donc
mec
les gens me confonde avec toi mais ça
qui est un petit air geab son devoir
bats toi tu es d'en voir tableau et moi
je suis ton miroir oh oh mais c'est beau
attendait mais on est poète la sueur
omegle mais bien sûr quand les poètes
sur omegle hausse et un chien je veux le
voir je veux voir le chien jack jack y
ait 50 ans jacky
[ __ ] en hameaux cette situation en un
mot un seul mot impressionnant saut
c'est pas très original mais au moins
c'est bien trouvé
il m'a tuer il va flinguer il à dire
mokulu stable par rapport aux gens que
j'ai eu déjà un sosie
j'ai vu je suis tombé dessus a lâché
sauf si le moment où je passe à la
deuxième stratégique et la stratégie du
mannequin voici un malgache et les
mettre un pull
ok on y croit ou pas grâce à un fail
c'est sûr assez chez nous on s'est mis
d'accord
vous pensez que je suis sous la
casquette ou pas je relève la tête
compter jusqu'à trois fois
c'est bizarre c'est la première fois que
je t'ai ça a marché c'est raté
complètement lorsque marché est toujours
très bizarre sa mort je suis en main
comprend mais après la révélation sur
salut ça va trop de fils de [ __ ] et toi
tu pas mieux là surtout depuis huit ans
du fils de [ __ ] un stage là haut on est
où là
les canétois ok ok reprenons tous notre
came vous avez raison tout le monde
aspire un grand coup expire pourquoi tu
dis fils de [ __ ] alors tu as 8 en mai
mais pardon pardon quel âge un mètre 60
et alors je suis un mètre soixante dix
questions à faire je t'attendais tu veux
la bagasse actuelle tient les maigres
bisous awards
hormis la grossièreté il était adorable
ces enfants là c'était trop mignon non
mais c'est pas vrai c'est une [ __ ] de
photos fait voilà c'est relou cloyes
attend quoi non mais tu crois quoi tu
crois que c'est qu' un nom et compte
jusqu'à 3 1 2 salut mec ça ça va être ta
vue externe man ka ba ouai tour à toute
cette idée marche quand j'avais trouvé
une meilleure idée avec le fondeur
métier que c'est chouette parce que
aller même si ça fait genre une heure et
demie que chercher tout je suis tombé
sur plein de gens sympas et tous à qui
j'ai parlé donc ses co lotis
ça c'est une très belle morale que tu
vas te faire je suis très bon temps de
savoir ça en fait ça nous permet aussi
vous de vous retrouver les uns les
autres c'est trop cool et bat match m'a
fait bizarre de parler vraiment je me
sera le dernier de la vidéo c'était une
note très positive et agréable pour tout
le monde bah merci beaucoup
tu peux faire le trou de ma vidéo à ma
place peut-être mais tu mets une super
grosse responsabilité là c'est vrai et
ben voilà c'est la fin de la vidéo merci
beaucoup
ça m'a fait super plaisir de tous voire
de toujours parler j'ai rencontré plein
de gens junior n'hésitez pas à aller
faire un petit tour dans la boutique au
fisc dans la description non mais non
c'est trop ok ok pas reprend voilà on se
retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo
tiens
la jemaye l'outro là du coup là je lance
le générique est tout franchement je
sais pas tu sais quoi
bon je vais garder la tête je vais faire
la mienne en plus après ok c'est
justement quel âge as tu toi que là
dessus
quel âge as-tu donnez moi votre âge
mental tout est vrai retard et revu m
veepee chacun six mois j'adore je me
suis éclatée oif 0 on fait tous des
pizzas kazaa les 3/4 bisous kesa et
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de cette
vidéo omegle annuelle j'ai trop qui fait
de ce concept pour deux mais j'ai envie
de leur faire à la rentrée quoi ça m'a
trouvé rives
je pense à un truc qui est fou c'est que
vous êtes adorable et je suis sûr et
certain que j'ai fait le même constat
dans l'outro de toutes mes autres vidéos
mais gueule mais j'ai oublié et c'est
sûr que j'ai dit exactement la même
chose
eh bien écoutez c'était pas aimé la
vidéo si elle vous a plu si vous voulez
là un deuxième épisode avant l'année
prochaine je vous dis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo c'était grave
cool je suis trop content page est
tournée deux heures et demie on voit pas
le temps passer que ces bêtises allez
les amis je met les lunettes de soleil
ça pas en vacances bien évidemment
dorian orages et il peut donc je suis un
gros mytho
à bientôt il est à la campagne avec la
famille et me manque
voilà fallait un peu de tristesse en
cette forme vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]